let's begin so basically um
uh i want to just start with with
painting a picture here um so
you know every everybody
knows that
amazon has
a whole ton of products that that have
some ml component in them some of them
are very visible like
um you know things that happen on the
amazon website um the
the robots that move around the
fulfillment centers um of course uh
alexa
there's there's ml driving the the
supply chain
um forecasting capacity planning things
like that
um and you know there's the the uh the
amazon go stores um
uh but there's also
ml in many many places that you don't
see as well so it's it's kind of a
pervasive technology this is not unique
to amazon of course like this is this is
kind of the
the modern world um
but i think um you know
this has some some pretty big
implications um
okay so just taking alexa as an example
um i think alexa is a really interesting
example so you know what is alexa is
this sort of cloud-based service so we
know that um
you're uh
when you talk to alexa
uh the idea is that a lecturer is
learning from what you're doing what
you're saying is adapting to your speech
pattern vocabulary personal preferences
things like that so that means that this
is
um by very definition an interactive
system um it's not just a static
deployment of some some ml model
anywhere
um
so you know if we're thinking about
these kind of interactive systems and
um machine learning or ai that's been
deployed in the real world
how do we ensure that those systems are
robust how do we ensure that they're
efficient how do we
you know safeguard the privacy of our
customers which is you know of course
extremely important um how do we ensure
that customers are treated fairly by the
by the systems
um
so you know
always good to start with the definition
what is robustness um according to
wikipedia
uh i quite like this is
the property of being strong and healthy
and constitutional so we need our ml
models to be strong and healthy and
constitution
when transposed to a system it refers
the ability of tolerating perturbation
uh sorry i'm hearing a bit of background
noise i know some of these
not muted
um
and uh in the little c also section
you'll you'll see like see also fault
tolerance system and resilience so i
think you know
i think those are both uh interesting
points and it sort of speaks to me that
robustness is a bit more than maybe what
people think it is just uh on the
surface
um so we can think about maybe like a
couple of different failure modes
um and you know we can categorize this
patch broadly into into unintentional
failures and intentional failures so
unintentional
one uh ones where they you know the ml
system is kind of correct in a way
um you know you you didn't make a
mistake when you coded up the model or
you know during the training process but
something happens um
you know in deployment so you know there
might be outlaw outliers or anomalies in
the data stream that's coming in there
could be some sort of form of data set
shift um we may have limited memory or
you know other compute problems um and
there could be you know biases in the
way that the data is collected
um and then there's sort of like the
more um
uh
sort of scary world of intentional
failures so this is you know maybe maybe
an active adversary trying to
uh trying to attack the system in some
way
um
so you know the picture to me uh
looks like this you know and i think
perhaps uh
you know i i don't know but i think a
lot of people maybe
see the title robust machine learning
and they just think about this like
one portion uh of oh i guess you can't
see my mouse cursor probably uh so i'm
pointing today i can see it
oh you can see it okay so this uh sort
of adversarial defense that's that's
what people mostly think about when they
think about robust ml but but i actually
think you know it's a much bigger
picture so we have to you know we have
to have this sort of ad activity to a
potentially changing world we have to
deal with security and privacy
we have to worry about like
biospherication in our models in our
data collection
of course we have to worry about
adversaries as well and then we also you
know want to be able to open up the
black box in some way so you know some
form of like transparent transparency is
also going to be an important component
to this
um so i'm i'm going to like touch on all
of these points during the talk um it's
obviously like extremely difficult to
try and cover all of these research
areas um
in one go um so i'll sort of like go a
little bit more deeply in some areas and
like sketch over a few others
um and you know hopefully i'll try and
like bring it back to this this complete
story um at the end
um so beginning with the with that
adaptivity piece
um
a lot of our machine learning models are
trained um on
static data sets you know we have
our typical thing is we have a training
set we have a validation set we have a
test set or you know we do some sort of
cross-validation whatever and most of
the models i mean this is not
exclusively true but most of the models
assume that the world is stationary so
this is you know the the distribution of
the in the inputs does not depend on the
on the time index
but we know that the real world is not
like that right so there's this kind of
mismatch between the choices of the
models that are being used and then the
reality of the systems
um
and and you know you could argue that uh
the
uh the sort of
democratization of of of ml that's been
going on so you know sage maker is is a
is a fantastic resource you can
basically do like one click deployments
now
um you can even do auto ml so you don't
even need to choose the the machine
learning algorithm anymore you you know
you pass in your data set and it will
sweep over sweep over models and hyper
parameter choices and
and give you outputs um you know
a very very high performing result
um
but this almost makes the problem worse
in a way because it doesn't solve the
the underlying problem
um so we need to we need to be able to
cope with
uh with changes that are happening in
the world
um so if we think about like
how data you know
okay this is maybe not true if you're
doing some like statistical analysis of
of a fixed data set for some
uh for some scientific purpose but if we
think about like web data
and data that's like collected um
from from the behavior of humans which
is most of what amazon does
we're in this situation where data is
arriving continually
it's you know possibly not identical
independent identically distributed
in fact very probably not
we may have tasks that change over time
um so you know this could be like
trends or changes in fashions and
shopping
you know we can have
new tasks that emerge so new product
categories new marketplaces like you
know if we have
um you know we've built our language
models to work in certain
certain languages and suddenly we have a
completely new marketplace open which
which which uh you know even if they
speak the same language they might have
different uses of of words so like how
do we how do we easily incorporate that
um
so then you know if we think about
robustness it's like how do we how are
we able to adapt to the new data whilst
retaining the old knowledge the existing
knowledge
um
and you know transparency
is is the component basically says like
how can we know if our system has gone
wrong so you know i think that's uh
almost as important as
having a robust system in the first
place is knowing when your system has
gone wrong
um so you know
sort of like standard approaches that
that uh people tend to take is
you know we just like train models on
individual tasks and we just keep
retraining retrain retrain retrain um
it's it's a
kind of a not very scalable solution um
you know be much better if we could have
some form of online learning or continue
learning um
and uh you know this is i would say you
know one of the most active areas of
research in in machine learning at the
moment
and there's definitely a lot of exciting
things coming out of it
um
so you know for a while we uh
um
we've been looking at uh bayesian
continual learning
um so
you know i uh i don't really expect you
uh i guess some of the readers of this
will instantly read this and
understand it and others won't so i'm
not really going to talk you through the
the details of the math here but but
essentially um you know we
uh
what we're going to say is that we're
going to like use our um use the the the
machinery of um
bayesian inference to keep our beliefs
about the world around and
we're just gonna do this kind of
resetting rather than like retraining a
model from scratch we're going to say
okay
the next time we see a new task or we
see new data we we're going to
basically use our posteriors from the
from the previous rounds of inference
and you know this could be applied in in
many different uh circumstances so this
same
kind of simple recursive formula can be
can be applied
uh just for like bayesian logistic
regression or for bayesian neural
networks or calcium processes
it can be applied to cases where you're
adding in
new classes so you know this this
capital t
uh sorry t is the task but there the um
the
the number of classes in yt could be
changing over time for example
um and this can be all all handled by
the the same framework um so it's you
know it's really attractive we have this
natural recursive algorithm
uh there's a caveat here as long as you
use some kind of variational posterior
so you know in truth the actual
like real real bayesian posterior is
going to be far too complicated
um it's not going to be amenable to be
used as a as a as a prior distribution
so typically people make pretty strong
assumptions about what what the
posterior is going to
look like in order to do this
um
so you know just an example of this uh
just to just to sort of like
put some some meat on it i guess uh
it is an example of how you might use
this in uh for generative models
so
the idea is that um
our training data here is just gonna be
uh images um
so we're first going to see only zeros
you know this is standard mnist type
images
and then on in our
the second sort of iteration of this
we're only going to see the digit one
and the third digit the iteration we're
gonna only see the digit two and our
task each time is going to be to
basically generate from any of the
classes that i've seen before
um so this is pretty challenging really
like you know on the first one okay
we've seen zeros we have to generate
zeros but by the time we get to this
third task we've seen zeros ones and
twos and we need to be able to generate
all three different classes of image
but it's a while since we've seen the
zeros and you know for digits there's
maybe only 10 classes here and it's not
such a big problem you know we can
probably just
exhaustively train on everything
um but you know if we had potentially
like thousands of different classes here
um that's a that's a much bigger problem
and the the the phrase that you'll see a
lot is um catastrophic forgetting which
is that
you know if you just train a neural
network uh to
um to to update
as you see more and more data it will
just forget about the past um
so the idea is that the uh
the we can make use of um our sort of
our
bayesian posterior to to hold that
belief about the past
um there is a caveat there um
which
which i'll come to first
so um
the
oh sorry excuse me
okay uh so the caveat is that um the
bayesian problem the bayesian solution
doesn't really solve the the
catastrophic
forgetting uh problem on its own you
also need some kind of model in there
of of the dynamics of how you expect the
the data to be changing over time
because otherwise you're
as you see more and more data your
bayesian posterior will start like
shrinking and shrinking um because each
time you see more data you get more
certain about it
and then like you know you as as you can
imagine like
as you roll this out to very very large
data sets you'll you'll end up with
basically point masses
um so
uh but at least like the the bayesian
framework gives you a way of
reasoning about like how my data is
expected to change and and how i should
uh how i should cope with that in the
same modeling framework
um
but yeah there are still some problems
with this like variational posteriors
that i mentioned they can be pretty
limiting
um you know i know there's some uh some
some work going on at bristol even about
uh about trying to trying to have richer
kind of posterior classes than
than the sort of naive mean field
variational posteriors that that people
tend to use
um i mentioned this point about their
the
collapsing to point masses and and
there's there's always the the elephant
in the room with bayesian approaches
they're more more computationally
expensive and they're kind of harder to
to
to train and implement and deal with
um
so you know
i think i think the point here rather
than like
hammering on about this particular
bayesian method
is that
this is still an open area of research
um and
uh that means that you know if we're
gonna do this um
if we're gonna try and
do something about it now in the real
world you know are we you know am i
gonna to
try and select some some like hugely
complex bayesian model or am i going to
try and think about how can i best
mitigate the problems using an
engineering-based solution
and uh so we you know we've been doing a
bit of thinking about this and
trying to think of what a like
what a
uh
a
holistic sort of system would look like
that wraps around your your standard
sort of ml model training
um
loop that you normally see
that gives you this kind of control that
you need
um so you know we you can think of some
basic components that you might need you
need sort of like
uh
you need to be able to
join the right pieces of data that are
coming in you might need to do some sort
of sketching or compressing
it would be um you really like to have
kind of a shared infrastructure you
don't want to be you know if you're
continually training or continually
updating models
and you don't want them running away
with
uh with memory usage and and and storage
usage although you know storage tends to
be
cheap compared to compute
um but you know and the idea here is
that the whole system should share the
same
uh resource constraints really
and you know much in the same way that a
an operating system manages its own cash
and deals with you know what what what
should be
what's like hot data what should be kept
fresh and what um what can be discarded
i think the same should be true for for
uh like an ml system you know keep
around data that you might need for for
reach training or or validation and make
sure that the the right amount of data
is there and it's updated when it needs
to be
um and then of course you need like
various different monitoring
and quality control systems in there so
you
you really should be looking at the the
input data is that is that changing over
time so can we can we have some kind of
data set shift detection in there
anomaly detection
um and and then kind of the other end of
that is monitoring what comes out of the
model so can we look at you know if we
don't have labels available at test time
can we just look at the distribution
over there over the predicted classes is
that changing significantly so if my
model starts predicting all of one class
when previously it never did that that's
a sign that something going something's
going wrong and of course you maybe have
like limited access to some
true like uh some some
uh
ground truth that maybe comes in um
sometime after you've made your
predictions so you want if you have that
you want to be able to tie that back in
and make sure that you're using that
um and then there's sort of you know
automating the ml life cycle
i spoke about like automl very briefly
but you know this is
uh
this is sort of like
the way things are going that we want to
try and take as many manual steps as
possible
out of the out of the actual training
process so that we don't need to worry
about
how we set up our cross validation and
how we do our hyper parameter
optimization
um
and then the last component here is
this model policy engine which is i
think a really interesting component
which is
basically like how do i make decisions
about what the best thing to do at the
uh
at any particular time is so you know if
i see that my model's doing something
wrong
you know what uh what are the mechanisms
what are the levers i have to pull you
know it might just be
kick off a training job
um or you know
escalate you know send a send a uh uh
a ticket out to
the on-call team or something like that
but but there's gonna be like
uh you know a whole bunch of different
ways that you can
basically like modify the way the system
is operating
um and
you know that in itself
uh you could imagine
being
somewhat of an intelligent system as
well i mean there's a possibility here
that you might want to try different
policies and you could start thinking
about well okay you know could i cast
this as a
as a reinforcement learning problem or
something like that
um
so
this is just a pictorial
um
representation of the same thing but
this is you know sort of a data flow of
we have our
our streaming data coming in and then we
have like our monitoring on the input
side
um the data gets sent to the to this
sort of trainer which is um
which is in charge of like
training updating models um you know
ensembling keeping them around whatever
it is um
and uh then we have this sort of
prediction monitoring component
um and of course we want to like link
this up to
any business logic that's there as well
um you know one one thing that
uh is often the case is that there are
there are business metrics which
um
which may not be sort of directly
comparable to the actual ml metrics
um so it can be you know you can have a
an extra sort of source of complexity
here as well
okay
um so
uh in summary like i think continual
learning is where
where the field is kind of going here
um but
you know in in my view it's kind of you
know there's there's these nice methods
but they're not necessarily like
production ready
um
so you know i think this this
engineering viewpoint is is is also
required
and
um you know there's a lot of work
actually to to you know achieve some of
the goals that i outlined in that image
um and
if i've got time at the end i'll sort of
touch on on that a little bit
um okay so
uh onwards and upwards um maybe i'll
just pause quickly anyone got any
questions at this point
i do actually
hi tom
i knew um i'm just curious how on earth
can you manage all of this
i mean it sounds great but i'm just
trying to imagine how i could kind of
have a finger a hand in each of those
cookie jars and uh
it could be kind of overwhelming i
reckon
yes right yeah i mean i guess like the
point
is that
um it it shouldn't be a single person
managing it at the end of the day i mean
the the i
you know the
i don't know if you saw the total the
title of this slide was zero touch
machine learning i mean zero touch is
maybe a little ambitious it's like
saying you know it should be you know
zero touch implies you don't touch it
this like runs by itself and
it does everything by itself you know
that's a bit aspirational but i i think
um you know low touch is maybe the way
to think of it so it's like if you
architect it in the right way
and you have the right mechanisms in
place to tell you when things are going
wrong then
then actually like the requirement of
the human always to be on call always
always you know always trying to work
out where things have gone wrong
should be reduced
does that answer your question
yeah it sounds great
okay
can i ask a quick question about this
um yes so um
where is the kind of incremental and
active learning fit fit in this
zero touch machine learning scheme so
where this can be
uh yeah so this that to me is in this
sort of like policy engine and
uh sort of training loop
i guess like um i mean active learning
is a good point you know i i
i guess if you wanted to do that
strictly you should have some kind of
arrow here which
which goes from the policy engine back
to your
data streams
because you want to have like active
data selection as well
and that's maybe not made explicit by
this but the the you know the
the point i made about this policy
engine like could in theory be an rl
system or it could be
an active learning system is you know
that's that's the point here so you you
know you have your under underlying ml
system
uh that's being controlled there
yeah that makes sense yeah thanks
and hi i have a quick one okay and you
mentioned um transparency and
explainability
in in the outline or
you know the circular figure that you
were defining to use robust
does that feature in your machine
learning zero touch uh model as well
uh yes um
and i will
get to it
um i mean briefly just to say
transparency to me is is sort of on this
this box around prediction monitoring
and things like that it could be you
know i think the
the phrase here could be expanded about
um
a bit as well
um
[Music]
yeah i i will try and get to that i i
realize that i've been hugely ambitious
at the time here so
we'll see how we do
um
okay so uh
i'm gonna um
i'm gonna switch to security and privacy
here and actually i'm just going to
focus on on
privacy uh for the moment
um
oh i want to go backwards okay
so you know um
if we're dealing with data that's
collected from uh from
uh from you know
naturally gathered organic human uh uh
human interactions with the system
um we have to worry about uh protecting
the privacy of the users and
you know
you might just say well can't i just
anonymize my data
and
this is what people did for a long time
you know they started there's this uh
very standard algorithm k anonymity
um which basically says uh
you know as long as i can't distinguish
from at least k minus one individuals
who also appear then then that's safe to
to reveal
um
so
maybe here you you sort of say uh
okay well if i start off with this data
set that looks like this you know i have
this uh this person the data set who's
you know working in london in the i.t
department has some
some salary there's probably not enough
digits these days for that but there's
the date of birth and nationality and
gender you think oh okay so you know
what uh
if i if i reduce this to the the
the uk
and then i put the date of birth into an
age range and i remove the nationality
you know is that good enough like have
we have we obfuscated everything we need
to know about the the the individual
but this still poses a risk right if
there are 10 females born in in that
age range in the whole of the uk's it
department
nine of them could work out what the
salary of the tenth one is um and and
the problem here that it's that we're
getting at is that this kind of thing is
not robust to side information
um and
uh i'm not going to go into these i i
think these are all things you can look
up but basically there's been many many
cases now where
uh
where data has been released in you know
in all good faith um
for research purposes or you know for
other reasons
and um
and people have managed to reverse
engineer
information about the people contained
in that data set so you know this uh
this uh mr massachusetts group insurance
commission was one of the the first
cases
um there's the netflix
[Music]
case which
just muted yourself tom what does
someone say to you
oh interesting okay can you hear me
again
yes can he love him okay
great
um and you know i think i think if you
don't know about these examples you
should go and look them up because they
are really quite scary um and you know
and the point in the in all of these
cases is like you know the data was
scrubbed and it was released to the
public
but there was always some other data
source that was available
that the the releases the data didn't
think about in advance so what can we do
about this um
so there are there are a bunch of
different sort of privacy enhancing
technologies that could be used i would
say that probably the most
popular one
and
[Music]
the most
i guess ready to use as a technology is
differential privacy
um so differential privacy formally
speaking is this is is a randomized
mechanism
um and we say that we have this like
epsilon differential privacy
if for two neighboring inputs um so
that's basically like if you have
uh
if you can think about it like this if
you have a database
and
a neighboring database where you just
changed the data about one individual so
you've either like removed an individual
or added one in
or somehow change what what's in there
that you shouldn't be able to to tell
the difference between those two
databases
um and and it's it's actually you know
it's a it's a probabilistic found that
you get um which is kind of interesting
in itself it's you know it's not a
um
it's not it's not deterministic it's
it's it's only defined in high
probability
um
but it it sort of protects you against
these uh
the exact kind of attacks
i was describing before
um
so like a really really simple way of of
producing a differentially private
mechanism
um
so you know this was obviously like in
1965 this was before the definition of
differential privacy but like later on
and the dp researchers realized that
actually the super simple mechanism uh
uh is differentially private so
basically if you if you want to release
a bit of information so just yes or no
you uh flip a coin and then if it lands
tails you respond with the truth
if it lands on heads you flip a second
coin and then you just respond according
to what the coin said
um and you can compute what this is
um uh this basically
tells you that uh e to the epsilon is is
three so this is like log three
differential privacy
um and it's just a pretty simple uh
computation of the
of the possibilities there
um so some important properties about
this uh we have
robustness to post-processing so you
know if if you have a differentially
private mechanism then any function
that's applied any operation that you
apply
over the top of that is still
at least epsilon
delta differentially private
we have this nice composition property
which is if we have
several different
differentially private mechanisms
then the uh the combination of those is
just the sum over the epsilons and the
sum over the deltas
and um and probably the most important
thing is this point about it protects
against arbitrary side knowledge so
there's nothing you can do
um as an adversary by like by adding
inside knowledge that will that will uh
that will
undo what the what differential privacy
does
um
so
you know
there's there's always going to be a
trade-off here so basically like the way
this works
um in that coin flipping example we saw
you know we are adding noise to the
answers
um
in in expectation over a lot of answers
you know if if we if we did that
experiment a lot of times we'll still
get
the right answer um in expectation but
for for smaller numbers um
then you know you you haven't you now
have noise your data and basically like
the the epsilon that you have like in in
that in that coin flipping example we
had a fixed epsilon
but you can imagine if it's not just a
simple
uh coin example but something where the
epsilon can actually be moved we then
have this sort of uh
um trade-off between privacy and utility
um
and you know
an example here is so this is um this is
pretty popular these days differentially
private sgd so you could basically make
any neural network
differentially private by uh just
slightly modifying
um the
the algorithm so you you basically have
this
uh this noise variance that you add to
your gradients and then you do this
gradient clipping as well um which is
just needed there to make the to make
the proofs go through
um
and then you have this um
you
you basically have the
the differential privacy guarantees for
any neural network you can trade
um this poses a problem though which is
that you have you now have extra hyper
parameters so you had your
all of your neural network parameters
that you already had your you know your
batch sizes and epochs and
learning rates or whatever but we we now
have two extra parameters from from
differential privacy
um and
you know optimizing
uh
simultaneously for utility and privacy
is is going to be a challenge here
um so just like in pictures what this
looks like is
um we have a bunch of uh we have this
like hyperparameter space which is as i
said is like your neural network
parameters plus your
privacy parameters
and then you know at each point in the
space you're going to get a
uh something like a test error or you
know some some way of evaluating your
your uh your model
um
plus some epsilon value
so basically depending on how you set
all of your hyper parameters you'll get
a different uh you'll get a different
privacy loss and and interestingly like
the
um
[Music]
the
privacy guarantees
depend not only on the hyper parameters
of the of the differential privacy they
also depend can depend on the
neural network hyper parameters as well
so for example like
because you're adding noise at every
single gradient step if you have more
batches or you know uh
uh
or if you stop early you're gonna have a
different incurred privacy loss than
than if you ran for longer
so if you run this a few times you know
you have a different
set of hyper parameters you get a
different error and privacy last
and we keep going and then eventually
what you'll be able to do is sort of
draw out you know you'll be able to
describe what's called the pareto front
so these are the the pareto optimal
points empirically speaking
which is to say that you know for any
given privacy loss i can't achieve a
better error than this or the vice versa
for any given error level i can't
achieve a stronger privacy guarantee
um so you know a question might be
um
like how do i
find the best
place along this so you could just do
this empirically
you know if you have enough time and
money you could train many many many
models
um but it you know you might also want
to sort of optimize this this pareto
front
um
so
again i won't go into the details here
but this is a
piece of work we did looking at using
bayesian optimization
in order to directly optimize this this
pareto front
um
okay so to sum up on on this topic you
know again i think this is this is
active research and is is
kind of
borderline whether you want to call this
production ready in a way i think you
know one of the hardest things is to
convince
stakeholders that a
uh
a particular epsilon value is is
meaningful um and
um
and that
the utility loss is uh is acceptable you
know people people spend a lot of time
driving for utility gains so if you tell
them that there's going to be a utility
loss
uh you have to justify that
okay i'm gonna pause again
any questions on this
one quick one how big is the utility
loss typically um sort of have you found
that differential privacy really does
impact performance
yeah i i mean it's it's it's dependent
on a whole bunch of things as you can
imagine
um it's dependent on how much data you
have it is dependent on what you're
trying to train
um
i would say uh that that there
is almost always a loss there's this
there's there are some kind of weird
rare occasions where there's almost no
privacy loss
um and and you'll find there's a like
there's a paper which is called privacy
for free
um
privacy never comes for free but you
know i think the the point is you know i
think that was specifically about linear
regression and it sort of tells you
um like asymptotically as you get more
and more data
you recover the exact answer
you can kind of think that the noise
here could have some sort of
regularization effect
so you know if you if you
took the regularization out of your
model and then basically used bp instead
you might you might get away with it um
but typically like you know i would i
would expect like
a couple of percentage points difference
or something like that you know it's
it's
definitely definitely has an impact and
and you know as i said like if you're
trying to optimize for their like
third decimal place of your of your
accuracy then
two percent sounds awful but if you're
you know if if that's good enough for
the use case then
then it's okay
thanks
there's a question okay
what would be some causal approaches to
enhancing model robustness
causal approaches
okay i'm gonna
come back to that question i think it's
a really interesting question
but i i'll sort of think about that in
the background
um
okay so uh i realized like there isn't a
huge amount of time
um but i haven't actually got a huge
amount of content here either so
um i just think it's important to sort
of touch on some of these topics
um
i think you know fairness is is is uh so
you know bias mitigation and fairness is
a really um
also a really like
uh pervasive topic at the moment
um you know we have certain
risks
uh particularly i think when we have
data which is collected in this sort of
organic fashion so you know we haven't
we haven't gone out we're not
um
you know we're not like uh
pollsters or something like that who are
going around and specifically saying
okay we want like we want to collect
data which which covers like all of the
key demographics and it's exactly like
stratified and all of that you know we
we most of the time don't have the
luxury of that
so we need to be super careful
particularly if we're optimizing
directly for ml metrics like you know
accuracy or whatever it is
um
that we don't uh accidentally optimize
only for the for the for the portion of
our
training data who were the most
represented um
and there's many many kind of classical
examples of where this has gone wrong
um
and i think this is you know you kind of
think well okay where's the differential
privacy equivalent of fairness
um and the problem is like unlike in
privacy there's no single agreed on
definition there are actually like many
competing definitions and they you know
you read them all um and you can go and
find i think there's a nice talk
somewhere which is 27 fairness
definitions or something like that
they all make sense they all like you
know you read it and you're like oh okay
you know this this sort of like makes
sense as a fairness definition like then
you read the other one you're like oh
okay that also makes sense but but they
don't really agree with each other so i
think you know this is this is a really
kind of interesting
problem for for for the for the ml
community
um
so you know this is i'll just like speak
about one definition here just to make
this concrete concrete
um
you know if we think about like we can
think about statistical bias
um so that might be the difference
between
the expected value of an estimate and
its true value um is that a good enough
criterion
um
and you know this is sort of comes into
this like
uh okay well my model just was trained
on the data you know my model doesn't
have any bias in it um
but
you know it it
this isn't good enough really because
like i think you know as as
as an owner of an ml system you kind of
have to take ownership here
um
so another idea is is calibration um so
you know you're probably all familiar
with the definition of calibration and
philip david's is is a very nice one
which is you know if a forecaster is
well calibrated if in the long run of
events uh you know you assign a
probability of 30
um then they actually happen 30 of the
time um
so you can you can make a fairness
definition out of this as well um again
sorry about the like heavy heavy
notation here
um but it's like you you know you could
say
well uh
i could i could be
um alpha accurate by saying like the
expectation between my predictions and
the truth is within some alpha or i
could be alpha
calibrated
if for any probability or you know any
uh
point in the probability space
then um the difference between that and
my expectation is is less than or equal
to alpha um this pro has problems as
well though because you know you can
kind of gain this you can
um you can make a system that's
perfectly calibrated
um
and and you know just in the same way
that you could like make a weather
forecaster in the uk be perfectly
calibrated by saying
it's going to rain like 30 of the time
or whatever
you can do this in this this this
setting as well
um just like by by doing it within the
sort of the demographic groups
um so typically this is applied to sort
of like large disjoint steps over your
data
um but it's it's kind of not perfect um
there
there's this proposal of something which
is stronger which is called
multi-calibration um
which is basically saying like
the ideal thing to be would be to be
calibrated everywhere so to be
calibrated for every possible subset of
my data now of course that's impossible
the only way you can you could uh you
could achieve that is by having
perfect predictions forever
it's also computationally impossible
because you can't you know for any
reasonable uh size data set you know set
of features you're not going to be able
to to compute the power set so that
every possible subset features
um so they they define this sort of like
computational identifiable subset
definition which is sort of like okay
well i'll just randomly sample subsets
and if i have enough of those
then um then that's like gonna be good
enough
and you know in the paper they argue
that you can sort of throw in
the typical uh sets that you would have
been interested in anyway so you could
you can include your
um you know race and gender and things
like that and into those competitively
identifiable subsets but you
you you're sort of somewhat protected
against the the things that you didn't
code for
um
but again you know i think
you know i think there's there's not one
particular notion here
um which is going to save us
um
at least these things can be run post
talk and so you can do checks afterwards
and and there are some pretty good
systems for doing that these days
um
this last point is not clear at all um i
think some of the
some of the fairness definitions um will
uh will sort of like sit happier with
for example with differential privacy
than others but i think this is like an
interesting open area of research
um what's the time seven minutes over
there
um okay um
so i i'm just gonna sort of like wheeze
through and hopefully we still have time
for a couple of questions so i mean
probably like uh when as i said at the
beginning like a lot of people might
have thought oh here's tom's going to
talk about robot you know adversarial
machine learning adversarial defense and
you know this is this is a component of
it but i think you know the the fact
that these two have been like tied
together so heavily to me is is a bit of
a misnomer but i couldn't really give
this talk without speaking about it so
um
you know what is what is adversarial ml
uh you know in
in general it's like attempts either to
fool the models or to steal information
either about the model or the data uh
that the model was trained on so we can
think of like adversarial examples and
i'm sure you've all seen like the panda
that gets misclassified as the whatever
it is with a single pixel change either
these kinds of things that's your
sort of very very
um
sort of standard thing
i think these are interestingly sort of
like trojan attacks or backdoor attacks
so the idea here is like
if i'm using some like machine learning
as a service so i'm outsourcing it then
then you could train your machine
learning algorithm to be to do well on
the data provided by the by the user
but still be able to uh
to
do unexpected things on some particular
data you provide so you know you could
basically encode those single pixel
attacks into your model
um so don't trust
you know that would be like don't trust
a random person to train your model for
you
um a model inversion is sort of like
trying to work out okay what would the
you know if i just have an api access to
a model am i able to work out what all
the parameters uh are
in there
um and there's some some interesting
attacks there and the membership
inference is going back to the the
privacy cases like can i work out if a
given individual was in the data or a
given data point
um
and you know under under defense
strategies like the first four of these
i would have would say are all kind of
directly borrowed from
[Music]
just security practices in in software
engineering so threat modeling you know
that's what everybody does when they're
engineering a robot software system
attack simulation um impact evaluation
and counter measure design these are all
like very very standard practices
there's kind of nothing
specific to ml here
[Music]
i think this uh the the bits that are
specific like this this sort of noise
detection component um
that uh
that links back to
to needing a good anomaly detector in
there you know i think if you if you're
able to
to detect uh adversarial examples there
you know you'd also be able to detect
just like strongly out distribution
samples
um and
there's this sort of interesting phrase
information laundering you know there's
there's a defense strategy which is
basically i'm going to do something to
the input data
in order
that this type of um
adversarial attack isn't going to work
and you can imagine uh here that
you know a differential differentially
private mechanism might actually be able
to uh to cut to
to work as an information laundering
system
i'm not sure if that formal link has
ever been made yet but
um and you know just uh you know there's
a bunch of resources here um
i think there's some some interesting
libraries uh
the the robust.ml is is this quite nice
community run hub um where you can
basically upload uh
you know new attacks or new defenses
um and you know there's various
different places where you can
you can try out different things
i found like
nearly everything is computer vision
based so there seems to be a bit of a
gap here i mean
there are probably others who are
listening to this who maybe know more
than me about this but um again like you
know i think this is this is still a a
growing area of research and to me is is
not really like a solved problem at all
um
okay i promise to talk about
transparency um
i'm kind of out of time um
what so uh
can i ask the organizers what what the
deal is if we run over for a few minutes
or or would you rather not do that at
all i think in practice a few minutes
should be fine tom so um i i if if if
individual members
need to wander away that's absolutely
fine i understand we are recording the
session as uh most sessions are indeed
recorded so if anybody uh is forced to
get leave at 12 o'clock um this
recording will be available on the
website on the jgi website after the
fact
okay thanks um yeah so um
apologies to anyone who needs to leave
um
you know you can you can always reach me
by by email as well if you want to uh
ask questions and i'm sure uh sam can
provide that
um
okay so
uh again this is like a uh you know an
open area of research and i know that um
again there's there's people in bristol
who are interested in this um so i might
be preaching to the converted a little
bit here
um
but you know one of the one of the
issues that we have is like increasingly
that we're using these
you know black box or or maybe gray box
models we have these like extremely
complicated models if we think of like a
12-layer
language model you know it has 90
million parameters in it
how on earth are we you know okay you
can do something you can look at the
attention maps and you can try and like
work out different things and
um but i guess a more general question
is like
can i get simpler explanations uh about
the complex model in in in a kind of
model agnostic way um
so these sort of like additive feature
attribution methods uh try to do that so
they basically like you have your
complex model f and you're going to try
and use a simpler explanation model g
um which is going to approximate the
complex model just in the region around
a given uh input data point so it's
going to be like dependent on the data
and typically like what you do is like
you can imagine that there's sort of
like some your complex model has some
really like non-linear surface around
there but the uh the
you could use a linear approximation to
to the to that small region of space
and
the explanation model is basically going
to take a sum over the features or the
effects of different features uh in in
the model
and you know
you can just simply think of this as
saying okay my prediction changes by a
certain amount
if i include a given feature or don't
include a given feature um
and you know lime is is a popular
implementation of this which sort of
uses this very simple um
[Music]
uh
um objective function where you're
you're
you're minimizing that
basically the difference between
what your complex model and your
explanation model says
uh with some regularization over the
over the explanation model
um
and there's you know there's various
sort of different uh
um proposed methods that expand on this
as well
um
another another proper popular thing
which is uh
it's being used quite commonly nowadays
are called shapley values
so this sort of takes inspiration from
from game theory
um and the idea is that you have a
team of players uh with a certain payout
and you want to sort of distribute the
payout according to the players
um in a fair way and it's interesting
this comes back to fairness and the
shapley values have their own definition
of fairness so everything i said about
fairness and all the caveats still holds
here like this again is one definition
like uh efficiency the contributions
must add up to the total payout symmetry
if two players contribute the same then
their output should be the same you know
you read this and it's like oh okay yeah
this totally reasonable all totally
makes sense um but i think the authors
of the paper would say oh this is the
only fairness definition
it's not
um
and then you know if you're going to
apply this to your ml models like your
payout is now the the model predictions
and the players are the
individ individual input features um and
what we're doing is we're saying like
how much of the model prediction can be
attributed to each input feature
and the authors claimed in the paper
that this is the only
additive attribution method that
satisfies all of those fairness
properties
um for their given definition of what
fairness is
um
and you know uh i you know i'm not gonna
really uh
go into it more than that other than say
you know this is this is kind of a
a popular method method and empirically
seems to do quite well like these chat
values
uh so shap is a particular
implementation of the shapley values
is uh they much better with human
intuition compared to other methods um
but i think there's still some open
questions there's a lot of like
indescent
independence assumptions that are
encoded in the method
um and it's not really what
clear what happens when you move out to
out of distribution samples
um okay so that was kind of like
a very breathless tour of all of these
different topics and to me that you know
that sort of like
that whole thing every one of those is
is in itself a research area but that
whole thing is like that's really like
if we're gonna truly achieve machine
learning systems that don't go wrong
um then we we kind of need all of that
um which
makes us as as neil pointed out earlier
it makes like awfully difficult um you
know i think uh at amazon we're trying
to solve some of these problems you know
there's a whole bunch of
um uh
uh products in there in the sagemater
maker catalogue um and you know really
like uh
we're we're trying to make
life easier and make a lot of this uh
complexity go away for for users by sort
of like linking up really really good um
uh well-engineered solutions to problems
um so just like two of those so uh in in
the reinvent 2020 so just uh
just before
just at the end of last year um
sagemaker clarify was announced
um and this basically uh
it is is tackling the the the sort of
the fairness and the transparency so
they actually have uh implemented in
there
and they have
some some bias detection algorithms as
well
and
there's the sagemaker model monitor
which essentially is
is uh is doing the the drift detection
um and model quality metric
uh
detection that i spoke about before
um and it it links together with the
with the clarify service you also get
this kind of you get drift in in bias
it'll tell you if your your system which
was originally not biased has drifted
and become biased over
over time
um
okay so just like super high level
summary
machine learning requires more than just
like clever algorithms and you know i
think we really need to think about all
of these these issues um i really like
this book by michael kearns and aaron
ross it's quite you know it's quite
readable the ethical algorithm so i'd
recommend um
read of that if you're interested in
these topics
okay cool um
i am happy to to stick around for for
questions a bit more but you know feel
free to uh to drop if you need to
thank you very much tom for a fantastic
talk i will i will applaud on behalf of
everybody in the room
thank you um
i'm guessing there's going to be quite a
few questions quite a lot of interest
there's a lot of food for thought there
so if anybody does have a question if
they could raise their hand or type into
the into the chat as a first port of
call that would be fantastic um but
obviously if
uh yes then actually already is a chat a
question in the chat so
um i'll reach out for the benefit of
everybody here uh with monitoring
machine learning predictions for
distribution shifts and adapting them on
the fly is there a practical limit to
how fast the system could adapt or are
some changes likely to be too fast for
example for goods distribution having a
national border being closed with a few
hours notice is there any hope on the
horizon for systems that can be robust
to rapid shifts in circumstances
yeah very interesting question
um
yeah i mean i think uh
what that will depend on is is how fast
your
you know with this bit that i called the
policy engine
um whatever it is that's kind of acting
and making decisions on the basis of of
the shift detect and how how quickly
that can act and what what the kind of
iteration cycle is i think you know if
if you if you're stuck in this like
we have this gigantic model and we're
going to retrain it every time we get
like 24 hours worth of data in or a
week's worth of data then you're
obviously going to be stuck because all
of your
you know all of your scripts and
everything that have to run
um are going to be fixed to certain time
intervals they're going to be fixed to
like data collection intervals and
things like that so you know
if if
um you know if you have this case where
it waits for a week until it retrains
and then
i don't know you know like uh
like you say a border gets closed or
something like that
how are you gonna
you know are you gonna be able to kick
off a new training job or or you know
what's gonna be the policy that allows
you to update fast enough
i think as you move to away from that
sort of like fixed
time paradigm and you move to more
adaptive systems and more
like more like real continual learning
then you have the ability to adapt
faster
i it's an interesting one isn't it
because you you also don't want to uh
necessarily like
overreact or react to every every small
change that's happening so i think
that's
um
yeah i mean that's that's
it's a it's a really interesting
question there's kind of a flip side to
it as well which is that
if the change is so slow as to be almost
undetectable
then
i think you know it's gonna you're gonna
have a very very hard time actually
doing anything about that
thanks that tom um and i currently not
seeing any hands or uh further questions
in the chat um
i guess it means so
yeah well there was the question about
causality
which i think is is really really
interesting
um
i would imagine like
okay so so if you're if you want to do
some sort of causal inference
um
you you really have to be able to make
interventions
um
in some way
otherwise like you know if you're never
really going to be able to unpick the
um
the actual causal reasons of why things
are happening unless you have like you
know you you actually know the causal
graph perfectly then you might be able
to do it purely from data but
generally speaking like the causal graph
is unknown has to be estimated
um and then
the you know the only way you can really
do that is if you if you make some kind
of interventions people do make
interventions at the moment they do
things like a b testing and
um
you know other ways of
like running auctions and things like
that but it's um
not very well formulated i would say if
you do it using those methods uh
yeah
i
it's a good question i should uh
try and think about that more
there is one final question in the chat
which i think we may make the last
question just in the interest of time
apologies apologies anybody still with
questions um
the ai committee at parliament refuted
uh with the use of machine learning
models that do not provide a
satisfactory explanation and advocated
the use of multiple machine learning
models do you think we are too quick in
the use of neural networks uh where
simpler more interpretable models can be
deployed and do you think it's fair to
make such requirements become
legitimate
wow i mean uh yeah really really
interesting topic isn't it
um
i mean i think i think uh
you know
i was i always have this thing like okay
are you really gonna sacrifice
performance for for interpretability
that's that's one thing like say you
know say
we are designing something which is
going to be a
medical diagnostic
but do we do what do we care about more
do we care about being interpreted able
to interpret the model or the fact that
the model is right 99.999
of the time
and if there's right
99.99 of the time we probably don't care
too much about how it's actually working
um or you know it so you kind of had to
factor in what are the costs you know
what's what's you know for that
0.0001 maybe that's a really super
uh you know a patient unfortunately dies
or something like that that's that's a
really really hard sort of trade-off to
make but you know i think that's that's
one consideration the other thing is i
you know i would
kind of push back on
uh
a little bit i know i talked about using
simpler models to explain more complex
ones but
there are a lot of cases where simple
models
although they appear interpretable
can go wrong in an interpreter
interpretation for example like if you
just do a simple linear regression
and then you try and use the the the
weights to interpret that and you don't
have um
you know you you only have like a
diagonal covariance over your weights so
you've not you've not uh modeled the
covariance matrix
if you have correlated features in there
you're going to get incorrect
interpretations out
and that is a like a classical mistake
that is made over and over again so i
think you know just saying oh we need to
have simple models because they're
interpretable doesn't necessarily answer
the question
um and yeah and
i don't know do i think it's fair to
make it legislative
i think you know they're trying they're
trying to do the right thing aren't they
but
it's
it's a really really tricky area
thank you
yeah i'm closer now i know on that note
i can say um i can say it's been an
absolute pleasure to uh to have you here
today tom and i will i shall give you
another round of applause on behalf of
the entire room
okay thank you very much thank you very
much indeed um so the next meeting will
be sometime in march um and thanks again
to tom for agreeing to speak today uh
this recording will as mentioned be
available on the jgi website after the
fact uh have a very good afternoon to
you all
thanks again tom